[MUSIC PLAYING]
VLADIMIR MAKEEV: I
am Vladimir Makeev.
I'm CEO of Surf, and
we build mobile apps
and machine-learning solutions.
We have a strong design team
and strong development team.
We know everything about
the lastest technologists
in the world.
We share a special Google
list of these technologies.
And when some new
project comes to us,
we just look in on this table
and check if some technology
fits to this project.
And we decide, yes,
this technology
will be nice for this client.
VADIM MAZIN: A lot of people
say that we are all friends,
and we are like a family.
But Surf, it's a reality.
My name is Vadim.
I'm a PR Director at Surf.
We were among the
first companies
in the world who were
certified by Google.
This lets us have access to a
lot of early access programs.
EVGENY SATUROV: This is
two-way communication
between Surf and Google.
And we get all these
early access services.
But we also give
Google feedback.
And Google helps
us with problems
we have sometimes with
these new features.
VADIM MAZIN: For
example, recently we've
had a very cool experience
with instant apps.
We've had a very
good opportunity
to develop an app for
our favorite bookstore
and transfer everything we love
about it into a mobile app.
It was a very
challenging mission
because the bookstore
itself is very complicated.
We've discovered that it took
more than 100 screens to just
cover the functionality.
EVGENY SATUROV: Labirint
is one of the largest
bookstore in Russia.
Instant apps allow
us to convert people
who just Google the book
to the real customer
without even installing the app.
VADIM MAZIN: Recently,
we started working
on our very own product.
It's a machine-learning solution
for prediction analytics.
It helps retailers.
It helps airlines
to predict sales,
to optimize logistics
and supply chains,
and find the optimal
prices for each situation.
We've used TensorFlow for it.
We've developed it for a
very specific retailing
company in Russia.
But as it turned
out, the solution
can be applied to other spheres
from industry production,
airlines, hotels because
prediction analysis is
kind of a multi-tool right now.
Being certified means
certain standards
that we apply to ourselves.
We need to become
better each year.
Google guides us by giving
us access to technologies,
by giving us advice,
by giving us reviews.
VLADIMIR MAKEEV: The
main goal of the program
is to make the apps
of the world better
because you can focus on
really important things for you
like improving yourself--
VADIM MAZIN: --and more free
time to spend with your family.
VLADIMIR MAKEEV: --or
just sleep a lot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]